you just got your hands on the division
two but you might be overwhelmed by
everything it has to offer to help you
be the best agent you can be we've
compiled essential tips you should know
as well as important details about the
games various systems it's easy to want
to go from mission to Mission without a
break but it's important to return to
both your base of operations and
settlements from time to time to unlock
new bonuses upgrading settlements
unlocks new resources like officers who
grant you access to things like the
crafting bench clans and the dark zone
if you're unsure whether or not anyone
new can be recruited look at a
settlement on the map and it'll tell you
if there's a new officer available to
join the cause another benefit is you'll
see the settlements grow over time this
includes new rooms and areas for NPCs to
hang out and a cleaner tidier space that
looks more active this is more of a
visual upgrade rather than a practical
one but it's pretty cool to see a
community thriving thanks to your help
as you explore the world and complete
missions you'll naturally get the
materials required to complete projects
make sure to offload everything you get
towards them either by accessing the
projects tab in your menu or visiting
the proper NPC at any of the settlements
this is a great way to gain tons of
experience ensuring you're ready for
late gameplay sooner than later in
addition you're rewarded crafting
blueprints which is a nice perk to help
upgrade and customize your gear loadout
when you pick up loot if you're just
going to junk it later remember to pick
up as junk some of your junk can be
donated towards settlement projects if
they call for it so check your projects
first the rest can be sold and
deconstructed speaking of deconstructing
it's generally better to break down junk
for materials rather than sell it early
on at least until you have a healthy
supply for crafting
there's a plethora of side-quests in the
division too that you can typically just
find while exploring but don't forget
there's also several side quests you can
accept from folks at the settlements
make it a habit to check back often so
you don't miss out on cool missions like
a plot to steal back the Declaration of
Independence the Declaration of
Independence is still in the archives
building I'm hoping you'd be willing to
bring it back
once you gain access to the crafting
station you can use all the blueprints
you've been collecting to craft new gear
the thing is as you play the game you're
gonna be constantly collecting new and
better loot so when it comes to weapons
and armor pieces spending your resources
to craft new ones won't be really worth
it until you hit max level when you can
then start crafting specific gear for
the build you want what you should do
instead is craft mods they are level
agnostic making them always useful and
it's easy to swap mods from gear to gear
another thing to keep in mind that while
you can't craft exotic gear you can use
the crafting station to upgrade them for
example if you preorder The Ultimate
Edition you get the ruthless an exotic
level one rifle it may quickly become
useless early on but if you save it and
then upgrade it after max level you'll
have a dope level 30 exotic
choosing skills can be daunting since
you're not able to test them out before
spending shd tech on them
it's especially disappointing when you
choose something you thought would be
cool but isn't exactly what you thought
it was so to help out we have a few good
ones that are safe bets early on the
chem launcher offers several variants
but the fire starter and oxidizer are
great for melting away the armor of
tougher enemies
note that the chem launcher does take a
few moments to equip aim and shoot the
shield Barents are all good in certain
situations but the bulwark was
particularly great for getting out of
sticky situations especially if you have
a good sidearm to pair with it and team
players will definitely want the Reviver
variant of the hive skill since you can
revive teammates from a distance with it
safe houses aren't just refuges for you
to be stock on supplies and sell loot
they actually have computers containing
locations of nearby shd tech in addition
checking a safe house computer informs
you of the three objectives you need to
complete to liberate the area from enemy
control kokis on spending your shd tech
on every XP bonus perk early on it may
not seem like much at first but with
perks like headshot and multi kill
accolade active you'll be gaining levels
faster than players without them this is
yet another handy way to fast-track your
character to endgame activities
[Music]
one of the nifty bonuses you get from
upgrading the theater settlement to
level 4 is the firing range located in
the basement of the White House the
firing range lets you try out all of
your weapons from simple target practice
that test your accuracy to finding out
how much DPS you can dish out the firing
range is a great way to compare and
contrast weapons and will no doubt be
very useful for figuring out endgame
weapon builds another cool bonus is that
your exotics will be displayed on the
wall for you to appreciate brand sets
gave you extra bonuses on your gear
equipping three of the same branded
pieces can unlock the stat boosts and
perks attributed to that overall set for
example the providence defense brand
grants you plus ten percent skill power
plus eight percent health and plus 5
percent weapon damage if you equip any
three of their gear pieces brands are
easily identifiable with their
transparent logo next to the pictured
gear
you wouldn't think brand loyalty would
be so important during a post viral
outbreak but hey whatever you got to do
to stay stylish
[Music]
the division to encourage is playing
alongside other players if you're having
trouble surviving don't hesitate to call
for help or respond to calls for help
from others if you get a backup request
press pause enter the matchmaking menu
and then choose answer the call
don't let your character level get in
the way of playing with higher-level
friends the game Auto scales you one
level under the highest leveled
character in your party making it easy
to do later missions with your buddies
who have more time on their hands and
once you start the matchmaking process
you could even play while you wait for
folks to party up
if you find the listview of your
inventory cumbersome you can change it
to display as a grid instead by opening
the options menu while viewing your loot
simply toggle the grid option in the
menu and enjoy the benefits of tidy
organization were there any tips you
have that we didn't highlight here let
us know in the comments below thanks for
watching
you
[Music]